the sword in the stone this is one of
those movies I both really love and
really hate at the same time oh maybe
hates too strong a word but there's
definitely an annoyance to it okay let's
talk about the good stuff these are very
memorable characters Arthur is a naive
innocent boy and Merlin is sort of this
weird eccentric wizard who's trying to
teach him knowledge and wisdom it's sort
of nice having a film about Arthur that
doesn't dive right into the sword
battles and such but instead into the
philosophies of well being a good king I
like how we dive into the education I
like how we dive into him learning
everything well I guess here's my
problem with it that's exactly what it
is it's education and learning things
and it sort of goes at that pace it's
kind of like being in school likes if
you have an owl and Merlin teaching you
stuff as opposed to your boring teachers
but with that said that is kind of cool
but is that really what kids want to see
when they go to watch a Disney film for
me as a kid I did find myself watching
it on wad maybe because there was such a
laid-back tone to it I mean yeah Arthur
becomes a bird it becomes a fish it
becomes a squirrel and that's always
great for kids but nothing truly
exciting happens until the last third
when we get our villain man Adam in even
then she's more of a side character than
the main villain though she is a lot of
fun and that Wizards duel battle scene
was awesome I used to watch that over
and over when I was younger
if creative has just got some great
slapstick what's going on Julia hey hey
rip when I got older and I saw that the
film was in the video store I said you
know what I do remember that movie
leaving a big impact on me maybe I
should watch it again but when I saw it
again I actually found it a little more
boring than I remember the animations
not really spectacular
neither's really the backgrounds and I
found it wasn't really learning that
much it's got as good scenes but I don't
know if it really gels as well as it
wants it to I think I admire more when
it was trying to do than the final
product but that's it I do like the
relationship between
there in Berlin the side characters are
a lot of fun too though has anyone else
noticed that the boy clearly went
through puberty when he was doing this
voice but I've got to get back to the
castle don't want me in the kitchen he
was a monster the biggest fish I ever
saw there's literally a scene where they
played two clips of his voice back to
back and they don't gel up listen Oh sir
actor whoa
it sounds like two different kids but oh
well
the film is a bit of a mixed bag but I
am glad I saw it when I was younger man
I guess I'm glad I saw my was older too
there's a lot of creativity and like I
said I think it was kind of neat that
they took this very laid-back tone but
sometimes I think it works to its
disadvantage I can like it but I think a
lot of that is more because of the
nostalgia and the idea it's hard to say
whether or not the whole thing is worth
recommending but I will say if you do go
see it you'll definitely get one or two
really creative and enjoyable